bonsoir baraquements kenya merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur arte france le
premier au monde donc à homologuer un
vaccin contre la pandémie source de
fierté pour vous au royaume uni c'est un
grand jour demain quel est votre état
d'esprit ce soir je pense que c'est une
source de fierté pour toute l'humanité
ce n'est pas le royaume-uni est en
premier qui est important le monde doit
être fier que en moins d'un an nous
ayons réussi à produire un vaccin
efficace qui va servir toute l'humanité
c'est une bonne chose
alors vous l'avez vu en france il ya
beaucoup de scepticisme y compris même
chez les scientifiques ont longtemps sur
des plateaux de télé nous dire voilà on
n'a pas le recul nécessaire
on a eu pour l'instant que débridé
communiqué mais pas vraiment d'études
scientifiques vous n'êtes pas vous dans
cet état d'esprit en tant que
scientifique au royaume uni j'ai étudié
les éléments donnés par les organes de
réglementation au royaume-uni notamment
l' agence du médicament britannique et
qui a expliqué comment elle a analysé
les données et d'ailleurs cela fait
longtemps que cette agence étudie les
données elle a obtenu les données à
partir d'octobre et l'analyse depuis
cette époque et a continué à l'analyse
et jusqu'au dernier jour de la
production donc cette agence la mhr a
est un organisme indépendant qui n'est
pas soumis aux pressions politiques qui
est qu'il ne va pas faire des économies
rogner des parties du processus ce sera
en tout cas une grande erreur de le
faire donc si on vous comprend bien vous
êtes
c'est confiant à cette agence de santé
britannique qui a étudié selon vous les
les études donc s'identifie car les les
données scientifiques mais pour vous
c'est ailleurs il n'ya pas de frein
freins administratifs par exemple c'est
bien de ça qu'il s'agit
effectivement je lui fais confiance et
je n'ai pas de questions sans réponse la
question sans réponse par exemple aurait
pu être est ce que cela représente un
danger est ce qu'il y a des séquelles
des effets secondaires dangereux
toutes ces questions et des réponses de
la part de pfizer baytech je n'ai pas eu
un accès direct aux données
je ne travaille pas au sein de cet
organe de au sein du ce régulateur
mais j'ai pu avoir accès à leurs
déclarations j'ai vu leur travail depuis
octobre et pour moi c'est suffisant cet
organisme a pris une décision en un
temps record mais cela ne signifie pas
qu'il y a eu du bâclage pourtant c'est
une méthode moderne la rn qu'on n'a pas
encore expérimenté ça ne vous inquiète
pas plus que cela
oui effectivement c'est une technique
moderne et c'est une très bonne chose de
savoir qu'un tel vaccin fonctionne c'est
une très bonne nouvelle
nous essayons de développer des vaccins
à la rn message est depuis longtemps et
enfin la technologie fonctionne cette
technologie nous permet de construire
une membrane de nanoparticules afin de
protéger un brin d'air
l'un pour qu'ils puissent arriver aux
cellules et faire son travail la
différence avec le vaccin de pfizer
bayonne tech et par exemple le vaccin
spoutnik five ou les vaccins
d'astrazeneca
c'est l'utilisation d'une méthode est
différente afin de transmettre les rênes
de la porter à la cellule sinon le
résultat est très similaire alors la
reine et son époux pourrait se faire
vont se faire vacciner certainement ça
vous inquiète et d'ordonner l'âge de la
reine vous vous dites que c'est une
bonne chose
c'est une très bonne chose car les
personnes âgées qui seraient contaminés
par l'aco vite pourrait avoir une
maladie plus grave et seraient plus
susceptibles de mourir donc la priorité
numéro 1 bien sûr ce sont les personnes
de plus de 80 ans les personnes âgées et
ensuite les personnes qui ont des
comorbidités et on arrive ensuite aux
autres groupes est difficile à déployer
donc je pense qu'on va utiliser ce
vaccin tant qu'on a que celui là et
lorsque le vaccin d'astrazeneca et de
l'université d'oxford sera disponible ou
les autres alors nous allons déployer
ses autres vaccins afin de verser mais
bien plus rapidement car leur
utilisation est beaucoup plus simple que
ce vaccin riser baytech on parlait de la
reine qui va se faire vacciner c'est un
symbole fort qui pousserait également
les populations qui pourraient être
sceptique à se faire vacciner elle aussi
je l'espère mais le plus important à mon
sens c'est que les politiques ne doit
pas s'ingérer
les experts de la santé des experts
indépendants doivent être en mesure de
transmettre des messages clairs honnête
et sincère quant à la façon
le vaccin fonctionne comment ils
protègent quels sont les effets
secondaires afin de réassurer le public
d'expliquer que tous les tests ont été
mises en oeuvre et que le vaccin est sûr
c'est une stratégie au royaume unis
comme en europe comme d'autres régions
du monde
pendant kenya comment ça va se passer
demain vous ne faites pas partie des
prioritaires vous êtes encore trop jeune
mais comment ça va se passer pour les
personnes plus âgées elles vont se
déplacer chez leurs médecins dans les
hôpitaux de main parce qu'on sait que
c'est très difficile à stocker en ce
vaccin puisqu'il a besoin de deux gels
de grand froid comment ça va se passer
concrètement ça sera ma dernière
question au royaume uni nous avons 50
centres hospitaliers où le vaccin est
stocké dans des super réfrigérateur le
plus simple serait de vacciner les
personnes sur place les personnes les
plus vulnérables et plus âgés et ensuite
elles pourront rentrer à la maison ou de
leur maison de retraite ce serait la
façon la plus simple d'opérer dans le
même temps on pourra également en
profiter pour vacciner les
professionnels de la santé qui
travaillent dans ces hôpitaux ou autour
de ces hôpitaux donc étape par étape
nous commençons par immuniser les
personnes au sein de la communauté
hospitalière et ensuite nous allons
trouver des façons sur de transférer ces
vaccins dans les cabinets médicaux afin
d'immuniser les personnes plus largement
de manière très sûr même si c'est lent
merci et un baratin panka n'ya expert en
maladies transmissibles et infectieuses
à l'université d'exeter merci à vous